alors on va changer de sport à colleter
cédric 0 on va parler de aguibou doai
qui boudent au fait qu'est ce que c'est
que ça ce que c'est que ça tout à fait à
la masia pas trop connu évidemment un
pas beaucoup licencié en france mais
avant d'en parler un peu plus avoue
cédric géraud je vous propose de
regarder ce reportage nous étions au
budo au budo club de magny les hameaux
où nous avons suivi une de vos séances
d'entraînement
le maire de magny les hameaux connaît
connais bien votre club tout à fait on a
vu samedi des gens forment des réseaux
sociaux
alors l on va voir ce reportage tout de
suite c'était donc c'est à magny les
hameaux on a suivi une séance on me dit
si c'est ok au pas ou quand je suis
debout
l'aïe qui bout d'os ou la voie des
énergies unifiée c'est un art martial
créé à l'ère des vals par les chefs de
clans japonais arrivé il ya seulement 30
ans en france est enseignée au budo club
de magny les hameaux lie thibodeau reste
un art martial de défense toujours dans
une volonté d' équilibre où il faut
utiliser les mouvements de son
partenaire pour riposter et le mettre à
terre tout en gardant le contrôle
l'atv dos et bien effectivement un art
martial de défense comme le voulait
mettre you chiba à l'origine de l'aïkido
on utilise toujours l'énergie en fait de
l'adversaire pour le canaliser et la
retourner contre lui on considère
vraiment la personne qui travaille avec
nous c'est notre partenaire il
un respect qui est très important au
niveau de l'équipe aussi j'aime bien
faire le distinguo qu avec ces
passeports de combat c'est vraiment un
art martial un art martial est là pour
vraiment développer l' harmonie avec le
partenaire les quais articulaires sont
tout aussi importantes que
l'apprentissage de la chute sans un
contact parfait avec le seul les
mouvements peuvent vite devenir
dangereux d'où l'importance de contrôler
riposte et partenaires à la fois une
retenue qui permet de voir le quotidien
autrement
à la sortie du tatami une philosophie du
surnom d' agression un défraiement la
discipline peut-être un peu plus de
calme par rapport aux agressions de la
vie de tous les jours
le stress de tous les jours comme on
vient on vit des situations stressantes
contrôler finalement ça nous aide dans
la vie tous les jours peut-être sur des
situations un peu je dirais inhabituel
agressive et bien avoir une réaction un
peu comme on va voir sur le tatami le
maniement des armes
l'autre facette de laeken donc plutôt à
la lance les techniques de combat sont
regroupées sous le terme de kobudo
quelle que soit la technique il n'y a
pas réellement d'affrontements pas de
vainqueur ni de vaincu mais deux
partenaires sur le tatami alors c'est
vrai que quand nous sommes venus vous
voir au budo club ce qui m'avait frappé
c'était cet aspect partenaires et non
pas adversaires qu'on connaît souvent
dans l'est dans les arts martiaux vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
justement là-dessus oui c'est on aime
bien faire ce le distinguo entre un
adversaire 20 partenaires on est
vraiment un art martial si on n'est pas
un sport de combat sont pratique un art
guerrier un qui comme voulu 10,6 me
séjours originaux niveau du japon
médiéval les premières techniques ont
utilisé
dates du 10ème siècle donc oui on essaie
on parle de partenaires parce que c'est
quelqu'un avec qui on va travailler tout
au long de l'année on n'est pas en
conflit avec lui il est là pour nous
apprendre à progresser pour nous
apprendre à développer notre technique
notre pratique et c'est un échange
vraiment perpétuelle quand on est sur le
tatami ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
que l'on met en avant sur le club et sur
la pratique de l'aïkido
alors du coup cette notion de
partenaires induites il n'y a pas de
compétition à proprement parler de
combat cessa mais on peut quand même
évolué dans cet art martial faut
rassurer les téléspectateurs des
spectateurs il n'y a pas un gain grade
et puis c'est tout après on s'arrête pas
la compétition est pas vraiment pas le
but est la philosophie de l'aïkibudo
comme l'aïkido
pourquoi parce qu'en plus on travaille
beaucoup sur l'excellent articulaires
écrit articulaires peuvent être très
vite dangereuse donc si on faisait une
compétition entre deux partenaires si on
avait un qui est un petit peu en retard
on va vite à l'accident donc c'est des
choses sur lequel on
mais vraiment le pas par rapport à ça
les gens peuvent évoluer
il n'y a pas de souci on passe des
grades c'est là que pour aller jusqu'à
la ceinture noire parce qu'on appelle
des kew vous avez vu dans le reportage
tous les jeunes pratiquants qui ont une
ceinture blanche sont en fait des kew
donc le premier grade qui vont passer
c'est le sixième ku des kew et ses tubes
d'accord c'est à 10 ans comme non c'est
pour ça c'est un terme japonais cave et
moi j'interviens dans le plateau pendant
est donc le premier à redon qui passe
c'est le sixième kg où ils vont passer
jusqu'au 1er kyu donc ça se dégrade
qu'on passe à l'intérieur du club
à partir du moment où ils veulent passer
l'équivalent de 2 à la ceinture par
exemple le caractère le 1er kyu ça
serait ceinture marron et on irait on va
là on est à peu près aux ceintures
jaunes et certains clubs qui aiment à
faire passer les des ceintures de
couleurs est-ce que ça aide aussi les
gens à se rendre un petit peu comptes
qui fait quoi sur le tatami c'est bon
c'est un peu la philosophie européenne
ça c'est on a besoin de savoir où est-ce
qu'on est placé dans la hiérarchie
nous ne restait quand même très proche
fabrice bergot de de la discipline
japonaise on est blanc jusqu'à la
ceinture noire et à la ceinture noire on
va passer devant le jury national qui va
nous noté et si on a bien effectué tous
les séries en fait de mouvement imposées
pour passer le 1er dan on obtient la
ceinture noire et on peut porter la jupe
culotte traditionnelle japonaise qu'on
appelle le hakama que les samouraïs
c'est encore une question pertinente à
la pause et parce que par les deux
pilotes salaire assez lourd quand même
comme excuse des questions très
techniques
alors c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'ils
n'ont pas foncièrement disons qu'on
utilise plutôt un kimono à cp type judo
parce que comme vous avez vu où je suis
quand même pas mal les kimonos légers
comme le karaté s'amortit un petit peu
moins donc il vaut mieux effectivement
avoir en tête c'est un sport dangereux
non c'est pas cependant je pardonnerai
pas se protéger il faut se protéger on
apprend c'est la première chose qu'on
apprend d'ailleurs aux jeunes
pratiquants parce que c'est important
effectivement qui se met en danger
qu'ils apprennent à se contrôler ça
c'est vraiment une des bases pour la
progression est justement vous parlez de
jeunes pratiquants
on peut pas commencer le lay thibodeau à
5 ans comme on commence le tennis par
exemple
non alors ans quand il faut savoir qu'en
france en ile de france à paris et dans
l'est dans la province il ya des clubs
où il ya effectivement des enfants qui
sont licenciés équipe d'auch donc ça
peut commencer très bien partir de 8 ans
dans la région parisienne et plusieurs
clubs
il n'y a pas de pas très loin il ya à
côté de versailles
sur vence v10 il me semble qu'ils aient
des clubs enfants il y en avait un vent
à magny les hameaux
mais on a quand j'ai repris club l'année
dernière j'ai préféré développer plutôt
la partie armes donc le kobudo et on va
dire mais mon planning professionnel ne
permettait pas d'être la plus tôt pour
faire des horaires au niveau des enfants
et donc du coup on a préféré limiter
l'âge d'entrée au club à 14 ans
l'adolescent les adolescents de 14 ans
oui bon c'est à récupérer que les déçus
du judo non j'espère pas du moins je
pense que s'ils sont déçus du judo ils
seront pas déçus avec nous non je pense
que c'est il ya un âge effectivement où
il est important d'être un petit peu
bien dans son corps on va aider ce cela
mais il faut aussi avoir une certaine
maturité
c'est quand même un sport
enfin un art martial à ses guerriers où
on travaille sans complaisance mais
toujours dans le respect du partenaire
est sans lui faire mal donc il ya quand
même une maturité à avoir et la 14 ans
et c'est bien et puis surtout on manier
les armes
on m'a dit quand vous appelez ce bâton
alors le banana doit en fait non c'est
le terme japonais c'est un beau ken donc
keynes et le sabre est beau c'est le
bois donc bokken sabre en bois c'est en
fait avec ça que les samouraïs
s'entraider apprenez leur école de sabre
effectivement ça évite de trancher
directement les gens non il faut savoir
que quand on pratique c'est un sport
fort sympathique vous nous présenter ce
soir mangez votre ennemi ça fait ça fait
partie de cette culture c'est vraiment
une culture de guerriers les samouraïs
était tuschi ce qu'ils étaient 1 c'était
des gens qui étaient prêts à mourir sur
le champ de bataille
on fait pas ça aujourd'hui c'est un vrai
un peu dommage mais c'est un peu la
philosophie qu'on aime
et justement dans cette philosophie donc
vous le disiez d'art guerrier mais un
petit peu ce risque de blessure donc ce
que je vous propose c'est de montrer un
petit peu un geste basique avec moi j'y
suis totalement non initiés c'est vrai
que ce ne sera pas comme notre
journalisme non non je veux pas avoir
des problèmes d'accord alors anthony
vous allez rejoindre cédric pour une
démonstration
alors on va vous montrer un mouvement
qui très très simple c'est un moment
qu'on apprend aux jeunes pratiquants il
ya deux choses qu'on apprend jeunes
pratiquants chu teh pour éviter
justement de subir les clercs montre
juste avant tony en fait la chose si on
avait une clé articulaires à faire au
niveau du poignet si on a une inflexion
comme ça avec une torsion si la personne
ne sait pas chuter on va l'accident
c'est soit on casse le poignet ou celui
là bas donc dans ces gars-là c'est pour
ça que les jeunes pratiquants vont
apprendre à chuter pour se libérer de la
contrainte articulaires donc ça c'est la
première chose qu'on apprend la deuxième
chose c'est la pratique d'été aux 2 kg
co2 qui en japonais ça veut dire dénouer
les liens
ça se travaille face à face comme ça
c'est en fait on apprend aux partenaires
un style berrer au niveau d'une saisie
ferme pour que la route au niger pour
faire maman voilà
on contrôle donc c'est un moment assez
rapide c'est un moment qui perdrait là
il n'a pas lâché la main de long terme
sinon d'accord très mal
il n'a pas eu vent des milieux humains
c'est pas en travaillant fort c'est un
travail à ma femme qui fait un mètre 55
qui pratique et 2e dan vous direz c'est
un travail vraiment au niveau du corps
donc celle ci c'est le bassin en fête
qui amène naturellement la main devant
soi on vient la récupérer ici il ya une
torsion du partenaire qui se retrouvent
en déséquilibre confirme que je suis
tordre en comporte ce qu'on appelle un
atemi d'expression martillac qui n'est
pas marqué c'est juste pour nous le
client ont-ils de l'énergie au contrôle
son partenaire sur la distance et aux
flambeurs de la pratique quand on a
travaillé très près de son partenaire on
va s'éloigner plus en plus et les
partenaires vont apprendre à se déplacer
à esquiver les choses et ça au cours de
la pratique des des premier trimestre
commence à faire des déplacements
pourrait viser les éviter les attaques
est offert en deux jours après
effectivement on peut tranquillement se
débrouiller c'est la démonstration donc
en plus des activités qu'on peut faire
en coupe on l'a bien compris c'est ça
exactement tout à fait voilà bah merci
en tout cas d'être donc tous présentés
merci alors j'ai changé de place ça va
tout va bien très bien aller on va finir
merci en tout cas pour cette page de
sport et on va finir la page de sport
avec tout autre chose c'est du handball
féminin ce week-end c'était la reprise
du championnat de nationale 2 pour
montigny qui vise le maintien
les joueuses de stéphane paysans l'ont
emporté 21 à 17 une victoire lors d'une
première journée qui n'était plus arrivé
depuis cinq saisons je vous proposais
coûterait l'entraîneur inhibante un
forcément ravi on a eu du mal à rentrer
dans le match en fait
entré au monde en ont fait une mi temps
on est à moins à la mi temps on perd
beaucoup de ballons et en deuxième mi
temps on a des très très sérieux en
défense puisque on va prendre que
demain trois buts en deuxième mi temps
je crois donc il ya eu 21 17
c'est notre point fort normalement
devrait être sur la montée de balle on
n'a pas trop riche alan est en place
mais défensivement on a beaucoup
travaillé cette semaine sur la défense
je suis assez propres parce que trois
buts en une mi temps face à hazebrouck
quand même des grands gabarits c'est
très intéressant